[Applause]
can you make people do funny things yes
can you make people want to kill the
president of malaysia
it's not going to happen hello my name
is carl smith and i'm an international
hypnotist and hypnotherapist and i've
been teaching people how to use hypnosis
and hypnotherapy
around the world for about 15 years
today we're going to be looking at clips
of hypnotism and judging how real they
are
now you're feeling very sleepy
we do use focal points sometimes to
guide someone into a state of heightened
suggestibility
she is actually right that hypnosis is a
pure state of focus
that's all hypnosis is is a pure state
of focus
nothing more nothing less to start the
hypnosis process i could just say
just think about a little toe people
would be listening to me now but now
they're now thinking about the foot
i've already altered your state of
consciousness
the cup stirring and the way that she's
making that noise
to be quite honest that's not anything
to do with hypnosis if i was doing that
in a session with somebody
they would get really irritated that
type of conditioning
wouldn't really work you think it was
your fault
the young lad has got his eyes wide open
and having a reaction
as in starting to let go of emotions
that's quite common a lot of people
think that in hypnosis
your eyes have to be closed it doesn't
your eyes don't have to be closed
they can be fully open and you can still
have reactions and still
feel and have sensations of emotions
being released
and revisit a traumatic event and go
through the whole lot
and they're just staring at you and
going through it how do you feel now
[Music]
in hypnosis we can have a bodily
reaction called catalepsy
it's the stiffness and rigidity of
muscle groups or the looseness
and it is possible for somebody to feel
rigid or feel like they're stuck in a
chair
or feel like a lightweight being pushed
down on them
you can't i can't
this is another misconception you cannot
take somebody into hypnosis
without their knowledge without anything
without them putting up a fight if i say
i'm a hypnotist and they go i don't want
to be hypnotized that's the end of the
story
it's not happening go down the streets
of london just grab people by the arm
and go sleep and see what happens there
has to be a pre-talk and a preamble
there has to be something prior to the
event there are conversational
techniques that you can use
but on this length no that's not
happening
[Music]
some people have that sensation of
falling or drifting or floating so it is
quite
plausible that this could happen the
young lad is viewing
the person as a third person and that's
quite common as well
i would give this movie a three it was
more counselling and
misconceptions than anything ever since
i started working
um every single day of my life has been
worse than
the day before it so the most common
things that i see people for
are phobias anxiety weight loss stop
smoking
and and i predominantly work within the
field of post trauma
relax every muscle in your body
beginning with your
toes to your fingertips
i want you to relax your legs this is
what's called a progressive muscle
relaxation
where you would get somebody to relax
from the tips of their toes from the top
of their head and go through every
single muscle group
to get them to relax it's been squashed
for the tv it would be a little bit
longer but on the same token
this is quite normal for a session
[Music]
in this scene we see the therapist have
some type of cardiac arrest all it would
take was somebody in the room to just
say open your eyes wakey wakey or come
back into the room
it's not down to the hypnotist's
voice that they're going to be locked in
people get worried about that they get
worried about getting stuck in hypnosis
you can't you can't get stuck i'll give
it an 8 because it is quite
realistic however it's been amplified
just for tv so it does give a
misconception of
what we really do let this wonderful
80s classic soothe you
just a nice warm happy time
video hypnosis works but not to the same
extent
with somebody sat in front of me you
don't have to be in the same room the
biggest drawback is is there's
nothing better than having a human being
in the same room
because there are certain things as a
hypnotist i'm looking for
body language twitching the idea behind
the swirl is
as you're looking at it going inwards
like that all you're doing is focusing
in
on the middle of that so you're just
keeping focused you can do the same
principle by just holding your finger up
can you make people do funny things yes
can you make people change beliefs
in certain things maybe relationships
issues smoking you know post trauma
the way that they feel about perceptions
yes absolutely
trying to kill the president of malaysia
it's not going to happen
people's beliefs and morals would kick
in and that's you know
if you want somebody to do something
that's outside of their scope or their
morals and beliefs they're going to stop
but i do like this movie
i'll rate this movie one out of ten
[Music]
i am in your power boss me around the
pocket watch side of things
it's 1870s 1860s theatrics
it's got nothing to do with hypnosis you
could use the pocket watch
just to cause the focus but that's about
all it is
when i snap my fingers you will
transform into
a famous historian
look at me i'm a famous historian when
anyone performs like this
is that would they do that with hypnosis
or without hypnosis
because the chances are is that they
would do it without hypnosis
you are a young boy uh yourself
at 12 years old it's a beautiful summer
day at the old swimming hole oh my god
it is possible that you may go up on
stage to go
do something that's for fun
but the subconscious unconscious goes
well while we're up here we'll clear
this out
so there may be a traumatic event that
may want to come out
and as a hypnotist you have to always be
prepared for that
hypnotism can go wrong in the wrong
hands it takes years and years and years
of skill craft to watch people to
understand
i'd give that a four because some of it
was real but
it's so hard when you're dealing with a
caricature
by focusing and following the flow of my
words
as you're flowing and floating which is
why you're
focusing on my command we watch the the
hypnotist walk up behind
the the person and then start to talk in
some weird and wonderful
hypnotic language we have hypnotic
language but
that wouldn't happen in this scenario
with hypnosis there has to be a
pre-talker preamble the person needs to
know
where they're going they need to know
that it's hypnosis the snap-in
side of things i utilize snapping when
i'm clicking my fingers
but not in this scenario what they
they're trying to do here is to add on
to what they're doing so
you know amplifies the state when
actually it doesn't
when i use clicking or i use a clap it's
to
to to jolt the subconscious unconscious
to bring an emotion to the surface
look at the light listen to your own
voice now i've made the claim now i've
made the claim that octa 8
is pure magic but the truth is that's
just one of those things i said
the team apparently giving the young man
instructions via an earpiece you could
do that normally
i find it very difficult to believe that
somebody in that very short space of
time
could have got somebody into hypnosis
that's not realistic it's possible for
some people to have a natural hypnotic
voice but to put it on you don't need to
you don't have to do that the way that
you're i'm talking to you now is it
identical to the way that i would
hypnotize somebody i would give this
clip
a five because some of it is
hypnosis the subliminal work in the
background
but most of it was compressed and
condensed really for theater
it wasn't real hypnosis so on that i'll
give it a 5.
it's a hypnosis tape this woman at work
used it for two
weeks straight and she hasn't smoked
since so hypnosis mp3s and tapes for
hypnotists and hypnotherapists out there
i'm going to really upset them my
personal opinion on these
on mp3s is their placebo i think
if you tell somebody from a state of
authority if you go
if you listen to that for two weeks that
will change your life
it will change your life not not because
you've the suggestions
but because of your belief in a hypnosis
session you would do a lot more than
what they're doing just here
you would make them hate cigarettes
really amplify
the smell of cigarettes i don't want
that cigarette i don't need it
i don't want it in my body you want the
person to do that you are now completely
asleep
you don't need to smoke when people talk
about hypnosis they believe that it's a
form of sleep
it's not it's got nothing to do with
sleep hypnosis was a word that was
coined
because nobody knew a word in the late
18th century what to call it
so what they did is they said oh hypno
god of sleep we'll use that and it's
hypnosis
it's to do with just pure focus nothing
more nothing less
i'm going to give this clip a rating of
two palms up
very good resist
resist in this scene we've seen what's
called a hypnosis induction
the mechanics of what we're seeing in
here of the hands like pushing down
that's realistic i've done that where we
push down push down push down
offer resistance and then let go slowly
so they feel their body going
he feels and believes that the state of
hypnosis is being amplified
by that induction you don't actually
need one it's what's happened prior
to that event that you need hypnosis
starts
when it's mentioned my hand
they tied my hand with something
it's straw
we're seeing here is like a recollection
of events and
the the stuttering and the way that the
person's talking is quite
reflective of somebody that's been
through a traumatic incident you can see
within the body language of fear
of something that's going on as well
that's
common during hypnosis people's speech
patterns can change the tonality
the speed maybe languages as well the
smell
of spanding
rod in this scene here we've got the
five senses
he brings up smell first which is
quite common when i'm dealing with post
trauma it's normally the smell
that comes out first i'm gonna go for an
eight the way that it was drawn out
was quite realistic the only thing is is
it for the viewer that people who don't
know about hypnosis was quite a quick
process
it's still good you have come to the
right place
this is the ideal locale to lie down
and take a rest lots of stage hypnosis
would do this but it's not something
that i would i would recommend for
safety reasons because
if you're going to make people go into
hypnosis while stood up the variables
are out the window you just can't
control it you could have people falling
over left
right you could have people all over so
that's just a safety point for me it's
important that people realize that
safety comes first when we're doing any
of this
jesus stuff it
[Music]
it is quite possible to hypnotize that
amount of people
at one time and do that it is
but it has to be controlled and i would
have more than just me there
just dealing with that to have a hundred
percent like that
i'd like to know what happened before
but i would expect
maybe five or six people out of that
still to be standing to be brutally
honest
i'd give it a nine because it is quite
accurate what else makes you feel regret
they did it again one of the
misconceptions for hypnosis is the
therapist couch you do not need to lay
on a therapist couch to do hypnosis as
for outbursts
it is quite possible for people to to
sit there and
and say really dark things you know
you're looking at the person they're
saying really terrible things
and they're laughing at the same time
which obviously indicates there is
something far more deeper
and needs medical support
what is going to happen
if it's going to kill is it possible for
a client to get up during the session
and walk around
and grab something yes is it possible
for a client to self-harm
yes because i've seen it myself that the
only thing you do is just make sure that
you reassure them stop them from doing
what they're doing
and just make sure they're safe in this
scenario
i would refer this person straight back
to a gp or a physician straight away
anyway
if this world were to end there would
only be you
and him i don't touch people in sessions
there are certain scenarios when you can
use touch for making somebody feel like
they're going deeper into hypnosis
i've had people where they've started
grinding their hands and
started attacking their hands and
scratching their face as well that's
happened
in hypnosis sessions that's the only
time that i would intervene or touch
i'm going to give it a 7. i'm a bad
actor and a bad therapist the 7. the way
that the scene was constructed
is right it's more theatrics for the
movie rather than realism
i want you to close your eyes i'm
starting
right and now your mind is starting to
think
i can get hypnosis in under 60 seconds
so
i could start hypnosis with somebody in
a room that's come to see me who knows
i'm a hypnotist
and i have hypnosis in roughly 60
seconds 60 seconds to three minutes is
what i'm looking at
however it's not just about me just
getting somebody who doesn't know who i
am
and sitting them down and saying we're
going to do it because i need time to
educate them and show them and
get the belief system fired up rather
than just pouncing straight into it
[Music]
it's more of an irritant or
embarrassment
than have any effect on the hypnosis a
lot of people think it needs to be a
nice and quiet room
that's professionally would like that
but you don't need it was it hypnotized
that's quite an interesting statement
was i hypnotized that is a very very
common statement
of of people that have been into
hypnosis
and and lose time they lose time it's
very common
for if i'm working with people for
around 45 minutes to go i've been we've
been doing work in 45 minutes and i'll
say
45 i thought i thought was only him for
five but yeah it's quite common that is
quite peaceful as well to do it if i was
to give this movie a rating out of ten
because of theatrics in it i'll give it
a six there's some realism in it but
obviously compressed for movies